meme inspired cryptocurrency is shaking
up the investing world
in october the memecoin shiba inu
dramatically surged in value growing
over 1100 in the span of 30 days and
eventually reaching a market cap of
around 41 billion dollars
i think we've seen examples where
someone you know put a little bit of
money into something like doge or shiva
very early on and then they became
millionaires overnight shiba inu's
meteoric rise and subsequent fall is
part of a growing trend of meme coins a
category of cryptocurrencies inspired by
popular social media jokes sarcasm or
puns
i got 17 of dogecoin as a joke in 2017.
now it's worth 800 bucks
their surge in popularity reflects the
behaviors of a growing class of crypto
traders that are making a surprisingly
large impact on market prices i think
they see it as a good way to make money
quickly and sort of
try their hands at the investment game
but what's led to the growth of meme
coins and what trends are they helping
to shape in the world of cryptocurrency
so meme coins are basically like the
meme stocks of the cryptocurrency world
so there are cryptocurrencies that tend
to rise really quickly and really
sharply in value
largely because of buzz online to
understand the roots of the meme coin
craze you have to go back to 2013.
that's when dogecoin was created as a
joke playing off the popular shiba inu
dog meme at its all-time high the value
of dogecoin surged more than 15 000
for the year
so that means if you put a hundred
dollars into dogecoin at the start of
the year you would have ended up with
that turning into more than fifteen
thousand dollars even though dogecoin
was initially created as a joke many
grew to consider it a legitimate
investment prospect dogecoin sort of
became the test case for
meme coins and that's really helped lead
to the rise of other meme coins like
shiba you know
today there are hundreds of different
meme inspired cryptocurrencies and in
order to stand out effective branding is
key
meme coins are very community driven
meaning social media hype publicity and
viral moments largely drive their
success
for instance tesla ceo elon musk has
posted regular tweets about dogecoin
often contributing to sudden surges in
meme coin prices
so in addition to seeing this rise of
meme coins this year we have also seen
this subset within that of dog coins
kind of taking off so we first had
dogecoin then we had shiba inu and then
recently we've seen a lot of speculation
and excitement around floki inu and that
is because elon musk has a shiba inu dog
that he has named floki
another attractive aspect of meme coins
is their tendency to be very cheap
while one bitcoin costs around fifty
seven thousand dollars a shiba inu coin
is just a tiny fraction of one cent
as bitcoin ether and other established
cryptocurrencies become more expensive
cheaper coins offer an opportunity to
make quick gains
and while all cryptocurrency investments
are risky meme coins are particularly
volatile prone to double-digit
percentage swings in a single day
people tend to hold bitcoin a bit longer
than they do
sheba or dogecoin and so i think that
can add to a lot of volatility
one reason for this volatility is a lack
of built-in scarcity bitcoin has a
finite supply of 21 million coins
creating value similar to the way gold
is valuable because it's scarce
meanwhile many meme coins are
inflationary meaning they have unlimited
or extremely high supply caps
shiba inu for instance started with a
cap of one quadrillion coins that's one
million billions
over time a nearly unlimited cap on
supply can negatively impact value
there's um you know a cap on the number
of bitcoin um in existence and people
might be incentivized to hold it a bit
longer
many investors will trade meme coins
like doge or shiba inu on a short-term
basis hoping to make a quick profit so
while it is possible to make money
investing in meme coins this type of
investment is risky and can be more
similar to gambling than true investing
investors need to be cognizant of making
sure they're investing in something that
is legitimate we have seen
um scams happening in the altcoin world
just because i think everyone right now
is very eager to find the next dogecoin
or find the next bitcoin something else
to consider when investing in meme coins
is utility so i think the big proponents
of bitcoin um find a lot of value in it
because it is something that can be used
to
transact in the real world i think the
difference with meme coins is that there
isn't as much real world value
while the future of meme coins is
uncertain their rise in popularity
reveals that even the most
unconventional trades can lead to some
of the largest gains
it's hard to say you know when this
phenomenon will die down or if it will
die down i think retail investors have
been a much stickier base than people
are anticipating um i think it's going
to be really
interesting and exciting to watch